[Musique]
est ce que tu t'es déjà dit j'attends
qu'il se passe un truc ça m'ennuie de
voir à quel point vous allez faire de la
peine à votre père et sans savoir ce que
tu attends
est ce que tu en es
ou pas mais un truc et qui rendrait la
vie vraiment spécial
est ce que tu en es
ou pas
est ce que tu en mets
comment tu veux que je te réponde
puisque je ne sais pas de quoi tu parmi
ce que tu prévois de me proposer
ça promet d'être plutôt risqué mais
c'est une [ __ ] d' aventure nous avons
l'immense honneur d'accueillir certaines
des éditions est plus rare des états
unis
12 millions de dollars attend de savoir
comment ça va déchirer ta fait assez de
braquage pour savoir ça c'est
complètement stupide votre idée mais
qu'est ce que t'en sais qu'il y aura
aucun incident à l'aco je veux pas que
tu te réveilles alors qu'une dizaine
d'années où tout le monde dans ce qui
serait arrivé et qui tu aurais pu
devenir
c'est sûr que ça va
colas à ses basiques ses proches de deby
[Musique]
évite de toucher la maquette s'il te
plait merci
[Musique]
allez on y va